alors l'oeuvre que je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui est tiré de la
série membrane de pascal simonet alors
cette oeuvre est une photographie en
couleurs de tirages argentiques du genre
autoportrait de grand format et qui a
été créée en 2001 par pascal simonet une
artiste originaire de d'aubusson
limousin et qui vit et travaille à la
réunion depuis 2000 elle même un travail
d'exploration sur les limites
sensorielle et tangible de son propre
corps donc ici l'oeuvre a été
photographiée sur le sable noir de
l'étang salé et elle évoque en fait la
relation physique avec l'espèce alors
l'oeuvre une partie d'une installation
éphémère dans le procédé consiste à la
recherche d'une forme en passant par la
création de la matière et ce sur
l'espace alors la partie blanche est
donc une fille un fils de bobines de
couture qu'elle a fabriquée en adoptant
des gestes lents et répétitif letren
horizontale traversant son corps est une
armature en latex travaillé comme une
interrogation du corps center et d'un
territoire évocateur de forme
explorant les ressources de
l'inconscient qui surgissent pendant le
processus de la création
alors le volume construire avec leurs
lignes arrondies se referme sur
l'artiste l'intention des structures
découvre des ouvertures ou l'oeil
croiser le corps la sculpture devient
poésie de la peau pellicule ans le nu
dans une enveloppe transmissibles alors
mais l'or ou le déclencheur de
l'appareil photo est appuyé toute notion
de volume épaisseur et l'espace est
supprimée et sam hamad
élément au même niveau et plusieurs
notions de contrastes se font sentir
dans cette oeuvre alors il y à l'espace
et le vide
le blanc et le voir il ya un enfermement
et l'espace et le nu et le vécu cette
mise en scène nous transporte dans un
monde surréel nous procurant une
convocation ironique et sensuelle cette
création qui s'éloigne de la
représentation littérale avec un fort
rapport à l'inconscient nous fait penser
à l'oeuvre de louise bourgeois de qui
l'artiste est influence